Oh
until reached out to me recently to do
an unboxing of a new product of theirs
and normally that's not something we do
but they promised it would be really
special and what they sent is definitely
not what I expected from a company who's
known for making cutting-edge computer
technology because what they sent is the
Intel master system let's start the
Intel box master system this looks like
an old system it says copyright 1971
they've got games on here like polar
rescue where it's a simple game where
you have to try to catch polar bears I
don't know I mean there's got to be
something more to this because obviously
Intel is not putting out an 8-bit system
and let's see what's inside okay so what
we have here is sort of a chest that
looks like a console it's got a power
part in the back and a little connection
for what might be video but those are
both false so let's see what's inside
here I've got a little like a pad so
what happens when I turn it on nope nope
okay this thing just pushed itself
alright so this isn't an old video game
system what it looks like oh so instead
we've got it says intel core i7 unlock
process or Quarrie 7 is sort of their
top of the range line of cpus and the
unlock versions allow you to overclock
them beyond their factory settings yeah
there's a little sis Intel confidential
QJ e 64.0 i'm assuming four-point-oh is
the gigahertz rating which is the speed
but because it's unlocked you can
definitely raise that side
okay so this I think is really
interesting Intel is one of many
companies pursuing new storage options
that are both faster and slimmer than
traditional hard drives and so what
they've thrown in here is the Intel
solid-state drive which connects to I
believe a pci express 3.0 slot so this
looks like a little add-on card you
might typically put into your system
that would like you know Addis output
ports to the back but this is in fact a
hard drive that has a you know it's
powered by the pci express slot and
that's not as really fast that's what
you use to plug in your graphics card
processor typically which pushes a lot
of data very quickly so it kind of
looked like Intel plated little trick on
us but this thing is pretty neat and you
know it's this new processor from them I
believe this is one of their their years
or they just sort of bump the
performance up a little bit maybe five
ten percent over similar processors from
the last year so this is cool but I
actually think that this hard drive is
really neat because there's nothing
better than really fast storage and this
thing is foreigner gigabytes so it's
really not bad you can definitely
install windows on there in a few games
if you don't have any other options and
yeah you know intel is always putting
out new stuff so if you want to see what
else they've got in store that'll help
make your gaming better on pc head over
to int e ly / unbox to see some of the
new things they have coming down the
line
you